I don't remember even being on the show
I'm such a bad memory ten seasons 236
episodes and Courtney Cox apparently has
no recollection of friends ok no need to
panic
deep breaths everyone but don't worry
Courtney told Jimmy Kimmel on his porn
teen mini log on YouTube that she's
catching up on her iconic show I decided
to binge watch friends I remember
certain times in my life that I was
there so there's a chance she doesn't
remember this well at least we know
Courtney is watching the whole thing
from the beginning I just started season
y it's really good Jimmy then decided to
hilariously test her memory he brought
on his cousin Anthony who's a friend's
fanatic to face off against Courtney and
a few rounds of friends trivia by the
end of this quarantine I'm gonna know so
much more of it go ahead
I'm from quizzing them on who Monica's
first kiss well Ross is correct yes it
was - remembering who officiated Monica
and Chandler's wedding
dearly beloved I'm sorry I'm a little
late in the end Courtney came up very
very short and Anthony dominated with 5
to 0 so embarrassing I know the actress
also revealed that she's been in self
quarantine for two weeks she's been
keeping busy by showing off her dance
moves on tip talk and performing musical
covers with her 15 year old daughter
Coco
[Music]
Koko's really she's into musical theater
and she's done probably 22 plays already
she's absolutely obsessed the pandemic
has also put a halt to the highly
anticipated friends reunion that's been
in the works for months at HBO max we're
supposed to do it Monday and Tuesday of
this week but she added that the cast
did see each other once before the
outbreak we did speak with the producer
one time and we had a meeting except for
David Schwimmer was in New York so we
were all in the same room et talked to
Courtney back in 2019 where she
reflected on the good times while
filming I just remember it being such a
amazing time we had such great writers
the whole thing was the best experience
that I could possibly imagine I felt
very lucky to have been a part of that
show and everything kind of seems to
pale in comparison whenever I read
comedies I'm just like you can't compare
I just we were really lucky and there
are just the friendships the chemistry
[Music]